pour les spécialistes il s'agit de ces
fameux restaurant où on trouve une
ambiance à nulle autre pareille
je vous propose à travers l'exemple du
fameux ici en tout cas café des
fédérations de faire connaissance avec
ces bouchons avec mathieu huget et
frédéric passe quatre reportages double
yves est le nouveau patron de ce bouchon
à la réputation centenaire dans ta salle
beaucoup d'habitués marcel à 83 ans une
gueule à la gabin et un passé de
champion ghoul et sur les bouchons c'est
authentique pionner en connaît un rayon
y'a plus rien même à lyon bien à vous
deux qui peut encore il distrait mais
pour vraiment les vrais bouchons est-ce
que ça a commencé à 8h30 9h c'est fini
c'est lille i
éconduit avec c'est pas fait pour les
touristes on va dire c'est à dire que le
touriste aussi bas il peut très bien
s'intégrer et profiter de l'ambiance est
appréciée quoi enfin est-ce qui est ce
qui ce qui pourra pénétrer dans l'envoi
dans tout l'ensemble ça c'est autre
chose comme cacher derrière ces stades
actifs de cochonnailles des journalistes
belges venus pour la coupe du monde
au menu tablier de sapeur andouillettes
bobosse et cervelle de canut leur
intégration semble réussi
la coupe du monde ici c'est quand même
plus amusant quand en allemagne
on mange pas trop bien au mexique avec
leur tacot âgées pas seulement 7 plutôt
indigeste 600 mineurs as une bonne copie
on a tous vers un autre à notre parfaite
celle de notre équipe ne devrait pas
dire nous sommes pas gai au mur pas
d'affichage coupe du monde tout juste
une photo de saint-etienne les profs
banderole plus il ya pas d assiette
coupe du monde les gris-gris et tout ça
c'est pour l'extérieur il finit dans les
années qui viennent pour l'authenticité
l'authenticité c'est ça c'est pas deux
les suivre via d'autres établissements
un petit les joueurs de l'équipe de
france ne viendront pas dîner ce soir
diététique oblige mais l'invitation est
lancée
thiébaut est d'accord ce serait pas mal